I want to go over the most common forms
of meditation how each of them work what
benefits each brain and also who each of
them are for next up we got focused
attention meditation how does it work
well technically focused attention
meditation involves any sort of
meditation where you focus on a
particular stimulus of any kind it can
be sound a sensation in your body or
even something visual like an object
what are the benefits to this
researchers have actually discovered
that focused attention meditation
activates and strengthens a part of the
brain the anterior cingulate cortex this
is the part of our brain used for
detecting errors overcoming impulses and
solving problems which suggest that
practicing this form of meditation will
help improve all three of those things
this form of meditation is perfect for
those of you that are looking to use
meditation to excel in school or in your
career as it trains your brain to find
solutions to problems more effectively
follow us for more helpful tips